aquí tenemos algunas imágenes que la
mayoría de las personas asocian cuando
piensan en química se imaginan a
científicos trabajando en una mesa con
diferentes frascos y químicos incluso
pueden pensar en un científico loco
hirviendo y cambiando colores o puede
que asocien la química con las
ecuaciones químicas pensando en cómo
reaccionan diferentes cosas para formar
otras o puede que piensen en los modelos
de diferentes moléculas que se pueden
representar de distintas formas o
podrían asociarlo con la tabla periódica
de los elementos y todo esto es una gran
parte de la química pero lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es que puedan
apreciar de qué se trata la química en
su esencia la química es una de las
ciencias que nos ayudan a entender a
hacer modelos y hacer predicciones sobre
nuestra realidad por ejemplo a la tabla
periódica de los elementos que la
podemos encontrar en cualquier salón de
química no le dan tanta importancia pero
este es el resultado de miles
de años y de muchos seres humanos
tratando de entender toda la complejidad
que existe en el mundo
miren si observamos el mundo que nos
rodea y no solamente tiene que ser
únicamente nuestro planeta si observamos
todo el universo veremos todas las
diferentes sustancias que parecen ser
distintas de muchas formas podemos
encontrar cosas como el fuego las rocas
el agua incluso en los planetas podemos
ver patrones meteorológicos en la vida
vemos toda esta complejidad y todas
estas cosas diferentes y parece que hay
una infinidad de cosas diferentes
diferentes sustancias incluso cosas como
el cerebro humano con su complejidad y
las interacciones electroquímicas y como
especie esto es un poco abrumador cómo
le damos sentido a todo esto no fue un
camino fácil pero después de miles de
años empezamos a darle un sentido y
somos muy afortunados de haber nacido en
el momento en el que nos encontramos y
de poder aprender de la química cómo es
ahora eso es lo que nos lleva a las
respuestas que bueno aún falta mucho por
saber pero eso también es muy
emocionante porque no queremos todas las
respuestas pero es una parte que nos
lleva a un largo camino y que al final
nos damos cuenta de que todas las cosas
como la tabla periódica de los elementos
y toda esta complejidad de la que
hablamos antes todas las cosas están
hechas de bloques básicos de
construcción imagínense es algo así como
los legos con lo que se puede hacer todo
y de hecho no hay un número infinito de
bloques en realidad existe un número
finito descubrimos más con el tiempo
pero no todo el tiempo ahora no se
descubren nuevos elementos tan
frecuentemente pero hay algunos de estos
elementos que aparecen mucho en todo lo
que vemos aquí todas estas cosas que se
ven tan diferentes pues no tienen
composiciones diferentes de elementos
como el carbono el oxígeno y el
hidrógeno e incluso los mismos elementos
están hechos de cosas como los protones
y neutrones que están acomodados de
diferentes formas para crear los
elementos que tienen todas estas
diferentes propiedades entonces cuando
pensamos en la química si visualmente
puede remitirnos a algo como esto bueno
estas son fotografías muy viejas pero la
esencia es como creamos si entendemos
los modelos que describen toda la
complejidad que hay en el universo que
nos rodea y para integrar la química en
un contexto con otras ciencias
muchas personas dirían que en el nivel
más puro tenemos a las matemáticas con
las matemáticas estudiamos ideas lógicas
que incluso pueden ser independientes de
cualquier cosa que hayamos observado o
experimentado y muchas personas dicen
que si alguna vez nos comunicamos con
otra especie inteligente que sea
completamente diferente a nosotros las
matemáticas podrían ser un lenguaje en
común porque aún si percibimos el mundo
diferente y pensamos diferente de cierta
forma las matemáticas
vencer ese lenguaje en común y después
de las matemáticas empezamos a
preguntarnos bueno realmente cómo está
estructurada nuestra realidad en un
nivel más básico cuáles son los
componentes que constituyen la materia y
cuáles son las propiedades matemáticas
que describen cómo interactúan entre
ellas y después de esto llegamos al tema
principal de este vídeo química que está
muy relacionada con la física por
ejemplo cuando hablamos de las
ecuaciones químicas y creamos las
estructuras moleculares las
interacciones entre estos átomos son
interacciones mecánicas cuánticas que
todavía no comprendemos a un nivel tan
profundo pero con la química hemos
empezado a hacer uso de las matemáticas
y de la física para pensar en cómo todos
estos bloques de construcción diferentes
pueden interactuar para explicar todo
tipo de fenómenos como por ejemplo esta
ecuación química que ven aquí es una
combustión el hidrógeno reacciona con el
oxígeno para
y energía y cuando imaginamos la
combustión a poco no pensamos en el
fuego pero qué es el fuego a un nivel
fundamental como percibimos esto por eso
la química es muy importante porque
después tenemos a la biología y como
pueden ver mientras estudiamos todo esto
hay puntos en los que todo esto se puede
unir y en el caso de la biología por
ejemplo en el ser humano o incluso en
cualquier especie la biología se basa en
interacciones moleculares es decir
interacciones entre moléculas y átomos y
al final todo eso es química y mientras
hablo la única razón por la que puedo
hablar es porque bueno es un poco
difícil de imaginar el número de
interacciones químicas que ocurren en mí
y justo ahora para crear este sonido
para crear esto que piensa que existe y
que quiere hacer un vídeo sobre lo
increíble y maravillosa que es la
química y luego con la biología podemos
construir todo lo demás como la
psicología economía
también consisten en matemáticas y otras
cosas pero esto nos da una noción sobre
cómo construimos y explicamos la
realidad que nos rodea y ninguna de
estas ciencias es más importante que
otra todas estudian cosas muy
fascinantes y como seres humanos primero
nos interesamos por el entorno y dijimos
o por qué estamos aquí que es este lugar
por qué existimos como existimos en
química construimos modelos para poder
entender las interacciones a escala y a
una velocidad que no podemos observar
directamente y que sin embargo nos
permite comenzar a hacer predicciones
entonces eso es lo maravilloso cuando
estudian química no lo vean como un
trabajo que el sistema escolar les
obliga a llevar hay personas que hace
100 años habrían dado lo que fuera para
obtener las respuestas que están ahora
en nuestros libros o lo que aprenden de
su profesor de química o lo que pueden
aprender en un vídeo de khan academy hay
muchas personas
el mundo del pasado e incluso de ahora
que harían lo que fuera para poder
entender qué es esto a un nivel más
profundo consideran un privilegio poder
aprender a este nivel y luego imagínense
nos sirve para pensar a dónde podemos ir
con esto porque en realidad ninguno de
estos campos está completo sólo
conocemos una parte de cada uno podría
decirse que hay una infinidad de cosas
que faltan por saber en comparación con
lo que conocemos pero lo emocionante es
que tenemos un fuerte inicio ya
empezamos a darle sentido para realmente
describir todo lo que hay en nuestra
realidad